here uh is anika heckel from the
university of munich
and she will tell us about the
non-concentration of the homatic number
please yes uh thank you for the
invitation and the opportunity to speak
here um yes so this talk is about the
concentration of the chromatic number of
random graphs or actually mostly about
when it's not not very tightly
concentrated
[Music]
so let me start by reviewing some some
background
on graph colorings um so first of all
what is the coloring
um so the setup is um we have a graph
um and we want to give a color to every
vertex
so that neighbors are always colored
differently
like in this coloring so whenever we
have an edge
the end points get different colors
and the question is now how many colors
do we need um to be able to do this
um and that's the chromatic number which
we denote by chi
um okay um
now by a random graph um i just mean the
standards
edit really random graph where we have n
vertices and include every edge with
probability p
um and the question of the chromatic
number of gmp
um has been around almost as long as as
gmp has been around
um so it was um already erased in the
foundational papers by erdogan rainey
and so there are lots and lots of papers
on this topic um and they
um so these papers can usually be
classed
as into or put into one of
these two categories so there are papers
uh that tell us something about the
value of the chromatic number
um so um usually these are upper and
lower bounds
now the chromatic numbers of course are
random variables so um
by this i mean upper and lower bounds
that hold
with high probability meaning with
probability tending to one
and the other main kind of direction of
research
is well how much does the chromatic
number vary
what can we say about the variance or
what's the length of the shortest
interval
that contains the chromatic number again
with probability tending to one
and as you might imagine from the theme
of this workshop
this is the direction i'm going to focus
on in this talk
but let me briefly say a few things
about the value of the chromatic number
um so much of the early focus
regarding the chromatic number was in
the random graph g and one half
so this is a very dense graph with lots
and lots of edges
so one reason why people are interested
in this graph is
that it's the uniform distribution um on
all graphs
on a n vertices um okay
and so um the chromatic number it's
i mean computationally it's kind of it's
it can be very hard to work out the
chromatic number of a given graph so it
takes
it takes a long time to to compute um
but whatever showed in in 87
that in fact almost all graphs have
asymptotically chromatic number
um well roughly n over log n
um so it was known that this is not
as a lower bound this is not very not
very hard
but bolobus proved the missing upper
bound
uh in 87. um so this is a very well
known result
uh and it was extended by woodchuck um
to almost all p um
[Music]
now for our kind of favorite random
graph g and one half
it was sharpened um by various people
over the years
um and the best bounds for g and one
half
that we have for the chromatic number is
um well this expression here
so this is an upper and a lower bound
and both hold with probability
tending to 1.
and the reason i'm writing out this
bound
or this explicit result on the on the
value of the chromatic number is that
later on i'm going to need it
um to say something about or actually to
prove
non-concentration um so yeah let's get
to concentration
um so um
this last result of course is already a
weak concentration type result
it gives us um an explicit interval
of length little o of n over log n
square
squared which contains the chromatic
number
um with probability tending to one um
but that's yeah it's it's sort of really
weak um
and if we don't actually have to be
explicit about the interval so
if we don't have to specify the interval
we can do a lot better than that
um so the starting point for
concentration type
results for the chromatic number is the
classic result by
chameleon spencer so also in 87 they
showed that
actually for any p the chromatic number
of gmp is contained in some
interval of length about root of n
so for this they use what is now a
completely standard tool
they use martingale concentration
inequalities
combined with the vertex exposure
martingale where you
sort of step by step you reveal
the edges of gmp and
generate a martingale that way so these
days
if you wanted to show concentration of
some graph parameter and gmp this is
part of our standard arsenal this is the
first thing you try
but they introduced this method in 87
and they used it to study to show that
the chromatic number is
is concentrated on root n values
um now in this general form this results
cannot be improved any further
because it's not so hard to show that if
you let p
tend to one at the right rate so this
means you have almost all edges in your
graph and only a
few of them are missing in that case you
can
more or less work out exactly what the
chromatic number is and
you can see it's not concentrated um
it's
not it's it's actually spread out over
root of n values so in this general form
this result can't be improved but for
specific p
or for specific functions p of n
it can be improved quite dramatically so
again our favorite random graph g and
one half
well if you work a little bit harder you
can
get another log factor out that was
shown by alan
um but actually if p
tends to zero quickly enough so in
if p is less than one over root of n
um then actually um it turns out the
chromatic number of gmp is two-point
concentrated
uh so this is uh was shown by alan and
kirillevich building on the earlier work
of
uh woodchuck um
so this is very very strong
concentration i mean let me ask
a question what is this point
concentration oh i mean
um there are okay there are two
consecutive values
um and with high probability
the chromatic number takes one of these
two values
wow okay so it's an interval of length
two
that contains the chromatic number so
yeah the chromatic number here is
basically
deterministic um because i'm saying
two-point concentration but actually
for most n it's one point concentration
um
yeah so this is a very very very sharp
concentration
um now all of these results so far it's
kind of a feature of these
concentration mating concentration type
results
none of them tell you anything about
what these intervals are
or down here what these two integers are
we just know they exist and the
chromatic number is
contained in them with high probability
um um
so for some p uh the two values or
in this case three values at most three
values were
worked out explicitly so archaeologists
and noah
there's a well-known paper by them where
they
worked out what two explicit values
the chromatic number takes in the case p
is a constant over n
and that's that was extended uh up to n
to the minus three quarters
um but they lose a bit of sharpness they
they can only specify three explicit
consecutive values
okay um so in the next picture i'm just
going to um do a review of what we know
um okay so the value we know
kind of approximately um
pretty much everywhere that we're
interested in um so this is an
asymptotic result
um the balabash result from 87 and then
the generalization by wuchak
we also have a general upper bound on
concentration by xiaomi and spencer
and as i said it can be sharpened
almost yeah maximally
for p less than one over root n
and we also know what the values are for
for even smaller p
um and so the
the range i'm going to focus on is in
this talk is
well the range where p is constant or
essentially anything in this uh gap here
um so we we don't really know what's
going on
here regarding concentration so far um
so in view of
some very sharp results showing
showing concentration of the chromatic
number um starting in the late 80s
bolobash and erdos well started
asking the opposite question so we know
some cases where the chromatic number is
very very sharply concentrated
but do we know if that's always the case
or are there any non-trivial
non-concentration results so i've
already told you if
p tends to one at the right rate it's
kind of easy to show
[Music]
that you can't do better than root n
but are there any non-trivial cases
where we know this
[Music]
so the earliest reference to this
in print i could find was from 92
so there added focus on the random graph
g and one half
and asked well can we show that at least
for this dense random graph g and one
half can we show it's not
the chromatic number of that graph is
not concentrated on a constant number of
values
and if you recall what the best upper
bound is the best upper bound on
concentration here is
root n over log n so this does not seem
like the most
um like the most ambitious
question um but still
it remained open for um for a long time
i think essentially because we while we
have
tools to show something is concentrated
we don't really have
a lot of tools to show something is not
concentrated other than
in special cases where we can just work
out the entire distribution
[Music]
right um so
[Music]
what about highlighted the question
again in 2004
where he asked for any non-trivial
examples of non-concentration
and noted that he would be happy to see
even the weakest results
claiming a lack of concentration
okay so the main result of this talk is
this
so the result is that the chromatic
number of g in one-half
is not contained with high probability
in any sequence of intervals of length n
to the one-half minus epsilon
for any constant epsilon um
so this result is joint work with oliver
readen
and we're currently writing up the paper
it's i'm very much hoping that this is
not 2020 plus
but that this is 2020. i'm quite
optimistic about this
um now last year this this paper is an
archive if you want to look at it
um i had this up to enter the one one
quarter and now it's
n to the one half which is significant
because this matches
uh the exponent in the best upper bound
that we have by alone
so up to this little or little epsilon
or little one if we want
um um
this result is basically sharp um
okay um now i should
um give you a word of caution about this
result
the order of quantifiers matters
so what we don't show is that for every
n
the chromatic number is spread out over
root n values
um and actually we don't believe that is
true so at the end of the
talk um i
i will show you a conjecture what we
think the right answer is for every n
and we think it depends on n
um but what we show is that there are
some values
n where the chromatic number is not
contained in an interval of length
until the one-half minus epsilon and
it's a feature of the method that we
don't know what these n
are so we can only say there are some
men we don't know
what they are we don't know if if it's
true for n equals a million
or not okay so um
okay so that's the plan um i want to
talk
about this the proof of this result for
a bit and then at the end
um uh yeah i'll show you
what what our conjecture is and what the
truth is um
okay let me first start by um trying to
convince you
why you should believe this theorem is
true
okay for this i need to talk about
independent sets for a bit
um okay so an independent set in a graph
is just a vertex set without any edges
between them
so set like this um like lack of drawn
here
[Music]
and the independence number of a graph
which we denote by alpha
is just the size of the size of the
largest independent vertex set
um now um independent sets
are kind of much more local than the
chromatic number where you have to
look at every every vertex and that
makes them
a lot easier to study in in random
graphs
[Music]
so for g and one-half
again we basically know what the
independence number is
[Music]
so the independence number of gm one
half
is basically exactly given by some
function alpha zero
which you don't have to remember but
it's some
function of order log n and if you round
it down to the nearest integer below it
you basically get the independence
number with high probability
of g and one half now there's
sort of some annoying things can happen
if this function alpha zero gets
close to an integer um so there's this
little one term
where if alpha zero is close to an
integer
um the independence number of g and one
half
might take one of two values but most of
the time
when alpha zero is far away from any
integers
we know exactly what the independence
number of g and one half is
um okay and we know even more about this
so if we count the number of maximum
independent sets
so independent sets of size alpha
because they are so small they are of
logarithmic size
they appear basically independently in g
in one half so in particular you can use
stein's method to show that uh
well the number of independent sets of
size alpha is roughly poisson
distributed
and um well with the right mean um
now what's the mean um the expected
number of independent alpha sets
um you can write it as some power of n
um and what the exponent is actually
depends on n
so um there are values of n where this
exponent is close to zero and there are
values where it's close to one
and if you plot it the exponent it kind
of looks like this
so this is a log scale because then
actually it goes up in a straight line
like this
um so yeah for some
some some alpha the expected number of
independent sets of size alpha starts
out
as close to one and then as you increase
n
um the expected number of alpha sets
increases increases increases
until you have about n alpha sets um and
then at that point alpha plus one sets
start appearing independent alpha plus
one sets
so here actually the independence number
jumps up by one
and the this exponent drops down
to zero again because now you expect
roughly one
alpha plus one set and then the same
thing happens again until the
independence number increases again
okay so that's the plot of the exponent
of the mean
of the number of maximum
independent sets um now uh
okay where where am i going with this um
now we know the number of alpha sets is
poisson distributed with this mean
um and we know that a poisson random
variable is not very sharply
concentrated
um it is it varies by about n to the
well root of the root of the mean and to
the rover 2.
um and if we pick some n where the
expected number of alpha sets is kind of
close to n
so if we pick an n that's kind of here
um this means that the number of alpha
sets
should vary by uh about root of n
um about its mean
okay so the so there are some n
where the number of alpha sets
um is not very sharply concentrated now
that's
good um but what does it have to do with
our problem
um so what what do independent sets have
to do with column rings
um well if you think back
um to the definition of a coloring
um so we wanted to color the vertices so
that neighboring vertices are colored
differently
well that just means that every color
class
is independent so all the other vertices
of the same color don't have any edges
between them because the endpoint of an
edge can't have the same color so every
color class
is an independent set
and just from this easy observation you
you get a lower bound for the chromatic
number
for any graph not just a random graph so
the chromatic number of any graph
is at least n the number of vertices
over the independent number
because no color class can be larger
than alpha of g
um okay so
um in a random graph this uh trivial
lower bound is actually
fairly close to the truth um so if you
think back to one of the first slides
where i was talking about
[Music]
the value of the chromatic number um
actually if you rewrite this
putting plugging in this definition of
the function alpha 0
you get that the chromatic number of gm
one half
is basically it's roughly n over alpha
zero minus some constant
um so that means we can color g and one
half
um so that the average color class size
is only a constant below the maximum any
color class may possibly be
okay and even more is true um so
intuitively it should be the case
uh that the optimal coloring the
coloring that uses the least colors of g
and one half
contains all almost all of the alpha
sets as color classes
so the reason behind this intuition is
these types of colorings
they maximize the expectation
so we think
they should be the ones that appear
first in gm one half
and if that's true and the number of
available alpha sets
varies by almost root n
then it should be true that the overall
number
of colors that you end up with should
also vary at least as much as that
because you have to take in all the
alpha sets and the number of available
alpha sets varies by
by almost root of n okay so
um yeah
so if you think back to this picture
that i showed you
on what's the
what the standard deviation of the
number of alpha sets is
um our conjecture is that the chromatic
number is not concentrated on fewer than
well roughly this many values um you
might have noticed i snuck a log factor
in here
um this is perhaps not completely
obvious why that's a log factor
so the reason is if say
t fewer alpha sets then you have t
times alpha vertices left over and you
have to color them
with color classes which are
of size alpha minus one or smaller um
and you yeah you you can always put
these
leftover vertices into you can always
group them
into color classes of logarithmic size
of into much smaller ones so
you can salvage a log factor but you
shouldn't be able to do
more than that okay but enough about
this
if you don't understand the log factor
that's fine um
yeah but roughly the chromatic number
should not be
more concentrated than about the
standard deviation of
the number of alpha sets and actually
our gen more general theorem
is showing essentially this conjecture
with a caveat so we show that
if s and tn is some sequence of
intervals
which contains the chromatic number with
high probability
um then essentially for every
n there's some n star nearby
so that this conjecture is true
and this is yeah and this is a feature
of the method we can never show for any
specific n
that this conjecture is true we can only
show okay for every n there's some
there must be an n star nearby it could
be n it could be um
another integer nearby so that
um this lower bound holds so that the
length of the interval tn star
minus sn star is at least well the
slower bond
okay although we think of course it's
true everywhere but
this is what we're showing um okay
um now if you have this intuition um
about um about the chromatic number and
the maximum independent sets
um um what might you try
to to to do about it um so
one thing i tried for a long time was
to take gm one half um and to condition
it
on some typical typical number of alpha
sets
so i put in kind of all the alpha sets
and conditioned on these being the alpha
sets
[Music]
and then i wanted to compare it to
another instance of g and one half
[Music]
but this time conditioned on a different
still typical number of alpha sets which
is a standard deviation away
from the original one and i wanted to
show that if
okay if you put in all the
these are extra alpha sets um then the
chromatic number goes down by a
corresponding amount
um or conversely if i have a coloring
and i take out some alpha sets
then this increases the chromatic number
by a corresponding amount
um we got a question on the q a if you'd
like to answer
us crs ask the following question
can you see the questions um
[Music]
oh yes no i can does this mean chi
is not concentrated on infinitely many
values of n
uh well i mean for for any particular n
everything is finite uh
i'm not sure um ah now i know what you
mean okay does this mean
is not concentric yes yes yes okay
there are infinitely many values n where
the chromatic number is not concentrated
on fewer than n to the one-half minus
epsilon
values because for every n there's some
n-star nearby
where it's the case but
[Music]
yeah we don't know we don't have
anything for all then
i hope this answers the question if not
um
follow it up uh otherwise i'll continue
okay um right
so um okay so the hope was if you put in
some more
alpha sets or remove some alpha sets the
chromatic number changes by a
corresponding amount
um now um
i wasn't successful in doing this um so
the problem is
if i have a coloring and i remove some
alpha sets
there might just be a different coloring
which doesn't use these alpha sets and
still comes out at the same number of
colors
so there was no way for me to ensure
that the optimal coloring even uses the
alpha sets
um so this is why this first attempt
failed
um so what did work
eventually or one of the main
ingredients of what
how to make the proof work is um well
we're not looking at
um g and one half for just one n
we're comparing g and one half for
different n
okay so the picture looks similar to
what was on the previous slide
[Music]
so what i want at the end which what is
going to be useful
for us is sort of a g
n one half um necessary
within uh or embedded within a bigger
gn prime one half so n prime is slightly
slightly bigger than n
[Applause]
and i want the difference of these two
graphs to consist entirely
of alpha sets and the reason i want this
is
then i can compare the chromatic numbers
of these graphs
because then i know the chromatic number
of the outer random graph
is at most the chromatic number of the
inner random graph
plus r because i can add all these sets
as their own color classes
now so for the moment
uh maybe you believe me this this is a
um
[Music]
nice gadget to have for the proof even
if you don't know where i'm going with
this yet
um so how how would i construct
um this gadget well what i
what i'm doing um or what oliver and i
are doing
um is just um
well we do um the most straightforward
thing
um imaginable so the non straightforward
thing is showing that
it works um we just plant
our alpha sets randomly
and then include every other edge so we
say these are independent
sets so they don't have any edges and
then every edge
every other edge is there
independently with probability one half
now what we have here outside of these
random alpha sets
is just a normal g and one half so so
that's fine
and what we want to show is that the
outer thing where we've planted
these are random alpha sets is
sufficiently similar to g
and prime one half so it's not exactly a
g and prime one half because we have
planted
the alpha sets but the idea is if we
don't plant too many of them
hopefully it's still going to be fine
and basically indistinguishable from a
normal gn prime one half
[Music]
now to show this um
it's actually cleaner to look of the
look at the effect of just planting
a single alpha set so this is what we
call the planted model
so here we just plant single independent
offices
uniformly at random from all
sets of size alpha and everything else
is just
a normal gn prime one half
and the key lemma is that the total
variation distance of
the planted model and the normal gm one
half is of order
one over root mu where mu is the
expected number of alpha sets
[Music]
and so this means we can couple gn one
half and the planted model
so that they agree with um quite high
probability probability one minus
well this bound on the total variation
distance
okay um now yeah i think i have time
actually to prove this lemma because the
proof
actually fits on one slide um
so if you want you can stop paying
attention for this
and then start paying attention again at
the end of the slide but i i
think this the proof is actually quite
nice because costs are short
um so basically we can work this out
explicitly
so the total variation distance for a
discrete random variable
you can just write it like this it is
one-half times the sum
some overall values
the discrete random variable may take
now random variable in this case is the
random graph model
so we sum overall graphs on n vertices
and we subtract the probability
that the planted model comes out as
exactly this
specific graph for n vertices
and the probability that the normal g in
one half comes out is exactly one
particular graph g
um now and we can write these
probabilities
so let's start with this one which
hopefully we we all know
the probability that g and one half
comes out as any specific graph is
the same it's the uniform distribution
on all n vertex graphs so it's a half to
the
n choose two the number of possible
edges
um and now here what's the probability
that
our planted model comes out as a
specific graph
well first of all our planted alpha set
has to come out as
one of the alpha sets in g so there are
x alpha of g choices for this
divided by n just alpha number of all
choices
and then all the remaining edges have to
come out exactly right
so either be there or not be there okay
good and now we just need to rearrange
these terms
so we draw out one half to the n choose
two
um and i want to write in the
denominator i want to write the expected
number of alpha sets so that's
n choose alpha one half to the
alpha choose two that's just the
expected number
of independent sets of size alpha okay
and what i'm left here with
is mod um x alpha of g
minus again uh expected number of alpha
sets
um okay and here we have a sum um
overall n vertex graphs we and the
weights here
are the weights these graphs get in g
and one half
so this is actually just an expectation
but i'm missing a factor one half here
but it's one half expected number of
well expected
uh expected deviation of x alpha from
its mean
divided by its mean okay and now we can
just use that
um we know that x alpha is poison
distributed
so we know um it's only um
i mean we know the the deviation
is of of order uh
of order root mu and so we divide by mu
we get order one over root mu actually
we don't need the poisson approximation
for this
um it's enough to show
that the variance is small enough which
is not so hard
okay so as promised um the this is the
proof of the
of the lemma um so if you've stopped
paying attention you can now start
paying attention again
uh okay so we know um
the total variation distance if we plant
a single alpha set
um then the total variations
distance to just the normal g and one
half is of order one over root mu
when we use the expected number of alpha
sets and now i hope from this
it's plausible that if we plant
well a little lower redmi of these alpha
sets
then the overall total variation
distance after repeating this
little o of root mu times is little of
one
okay so if we if r the number of planted
alpha sets
is less than root mu
this outer random graph g prime is
indistinguishable
basically from a gm prime one half we
can couple gm prime one half
and this planted
model to agree with probability
tending to one okay
so overall we've constructed um a
coupling
of g and one half and g and prime one
half
so that the chromatic number of g
and prime one-half is at most the
chromatic number of g
and one-half plus r
because whenever we have a coloring of
the inner random graph
we can add each of these sets as their
own color class
and get the chromatic number or get the
coloring of the whole graph
okay so that's the first main component
that we need for the proof
okay so that's the first ingredient so
we need a coupling
um uh
of g n and g n prime and is slightly
larger
um so that the chromatic number doesn't
increase too much
[Music]
and the point of this coupling is
if we now assume we have intervals
for every n that contain the chromatic
number
[Music]
and we have this coupling um
that in particular we know that the
intervals um
are at most are um the
the distance between them is at most r
um
because if we have some value so if we
take some instance of
of g in one half which um
the chromatic number lands in here we
and we couple it um or we take the
coupled instance
of g n prime one half the chromatic
number is in here
um and this is at most what we get here
plus plus r so the difference here can
be at most r
um okay so that's the first ingredient
now the second ingredient that we need
is a
kind of is weak concentration result
so the other thing we need is an
estimate for the chromatic number
which we call f of n which holds up to
some some error term
and we need this estimate to increase
sufficiently quickly
we need it to increase uh
faster than so we need the slope to be
more than one over alpha
um in the next on the next slide i can
explain why we need it to be
more than one over alpha um now luckily
this ingredient we already have
um so if you think back to the i think
second slide of this talk or maybe third
um there's there are the
the known bounds for the chromatic
number of gm one half
so we had this expression which holds up
to some error term
so and if we plug this in this as f n
and this of the error as the error term
and if you take the derivative of this
um it has this this this property with
an appropriate
delta um okay so
um okay what what do we do with this uh
now that we have these ingredients in
place
uh so the picture looks like this um
so this is the estimate for the
chromatic number the explicit estimate
which holds up to some arrow bounds
[Music]
and we know the slope of this estimate
is bigger than one over alpha
[Music]
and then we assume we have some some
intervals that contain the chromatic
number with high probability
and we know from our coupling that if we
go
from n to n plus alpha times r
um the next interval
um for that uh for that n
um it moves up by at most r so
this little the difference here between
the intervals is at most r
so the slope between the intervals is at
most
one over alpha because you go by
to the right by alpha times r you go up
by r
um and so now what happens
is if if all the intervals were very
very
short um this would lead to a
contradiction very soon
so if you if you kind of go from one
interval to the next and always the
interval itself is very short
and then the slope is also less than 1
over alpha
then quite soon you would get out of
this
range that we know the chromatic number
has to be in
so then here we'd have the contradiction
so here
the chromatic number would have to be in
this interval and then also here
okay so this is how how from those two
ingredients
uh you get a contradiction and if you
plug in um
so you know there has to be at least one
interval um
but you don't know which one it is you
just know if
if they are all short you get a
contradiction so one of them has to be
long
um okay if you um
plug in all the numbers uh what you come
out at um
serendipitously is exactly what you need
um
[Music]
uh so it's the lower bound from from
architecture which of course is not a
coincidence
it's it comes out because very likely
the conjecture is true
okay um
okay so as promised
[Music]
uh what's what what we think the the
true concentration and behavior of the
chromatic number is
because we've now only shown that there
are some n
or indeed infinitely many n
where the chromatic number is spread out
over
more than n to the one-half minus
epsilon values um
but we haven't got anything for all n um
so um i already told you
about the conjecture um of a lower bound
for the concentration that comes from
the
count of alpha sets um
now there's also a different lower bound
that's kind of similar but slightly
trickier to understand
that comes from the count of alpha minus
one sets
um and it turns out that if you
ban those two color class sizes um so if
you only look at colorings that don't
have these two
that don't have color classes of maximum
or maximum minus one
size then the number of colors that you
need
is actually very sharply concentrated so
this is a paper i'm currently writing up
with
costa's pie youtube from lmu munich
[Music]
again i'm hoping this is 20 not 20 plus
but here i'm
i'm not as sure as with the other one
so we're using
um the second moment method um or a very
complicated application of the
second moment method um to show that
what we call the alpha minus two bounded
chromatic number of gm one half is
actually two point concentrated
so this is again maximum concentration
it's essentially deterministic
once we exclude the alpha and alpha
minus one sets as color classes
now um from this work
and also um recent work
by uh wollabash morris
riordan smith there's
well recently a conjecture emerged on
what the true concentration interval
length
might be so this is the lower bound i
talked about earlier
which comes from the number of alpha
sets um
so this goes from n to the zero up to
n to the one i didn't label this axis so
this is the exponent
uh of the concentration interval length
so n to the one half here an end to the
one quarter and so on
um now the of course the lower bound
coming from the alpha minus one sets
which is slightly trickier to understand
um kind of goes the other way um
so this is the green thing and the
conjecture which we call the zigzag
conjecture
is that basically this is where all the
non-concentration of the chromatic
number comes from so
we all think the true behavior is that
the concentration interval length
kind of zigzags up and down between n to
the one quarter and then to the one half
okay um
right um yeah so let me finish with some
some open questions um so the big open
question of course is
can you verify this conjecture and
yeah i've phrased it more carefully here
thus isn't the case with the correct
correct concentration interval length
zigzags between
uh and to the one quarter and then to
the one half or if not what does it do
[Music]
another big question that is left open
is well can we um
say something about every n so it's a
feature of our method which
doesn't seem to be um
[Music]
i don't think it can be changed so our
method only finds some n-star
um near every n where the chromatic
number is not concentrated
um so it would be nice to have something
that's true for for every n
so as of now we can't exclude the
possibility that
um the chromatic number is not
concentrated
on some n on some sparse subsequence and
then one point concentrated
everywhere else which is of course um
absurd but
as of now uh the methods doesn't doesn't
really
exclude that possibility um
[Music]
so next up if we go to the very edges
of the conjecture so we have an upper
bound for the concentration interval
length which is root n over log n
[Applause]
now our lower bound is of the form n to
the one half minus little one where
the function little one tends to zero
kind of slowly um it would be nice to
to to close the gap between between
these these
um uh two expressions
um now we think um
we might be able to push this lower
bound to root of n over log into the
five
uh that depends on some results i'm
currently writing up with
uh with costa's panel too uh
okay so this would be then only within a
log factor of each other
um yeah and finally um
i was talking about g and one half the
entire time i'm pretty sure
the proof also works for other constant
p um
but coming from below up to n to the one
minus one half we have very sharp
concentrations so it would be very
interesting to know
you know where these two regimes meet so
until what point do we have
non-concentration
going down until we meet this very very
sharp regime
uh right thank you for your attention
thank you very much for watching doc i'm
very clear
are there any questions for the speaker
uh so i was just curious
in in regards to the second question
that you listed
is there no conclusion you can get
from your theorem about every n so you
can prove it for
that near near each end you have some
and star where you have everything
perfect
essentially is there no conclusion at
all you can get for every
nothing whatsoever like
well i i mean we know on average the
concentration interval length
um is the lower bound that it's supposed
to be
around n but at any specific n
it could be one point concentrated
so and another question is so you don't
think that
there could be some feature of i don't
know number three features at some
specific end will actually
uh you know give you some completely
crazy picture
there that indeed will fail
you think it should be generic
sorry i'm not sure i'm i understood the
question never mind
i i think the question was if there are
some
specific number theoretic uh reasons for
some integers and except for the
sounding of log
n into some other
um well we think the rounding of alpha
zero is the only thing that's
that yeah um influences the behavior
uh at least in the first order i don't
know what goes on with the lower order
terms
um yeah
so can i i don't know of any number
theoretical reasons why
yeah uh could i clarify something about
the
the zigzag conjecture uh sure uh
so if you could go back to the slide
sorry yes yes yes
uh yeah so you said here there's a lower
bound for alpha sets in the lower bound
from alpha minus one set so
you're not saying you actually have a
lower bound no no no
all of the i mean both of these are
conjectures this one we have verified
for some n
which we where we don't know which ones
they are
this is the sort of lower bound that you
would get knowing what you know about
the anti-concentration
of the number of alpha minus one sets
yes so this is i mean yes the number of
alpha minus one sets also
we know how much it varies you can also
do a poisson distribution
poisson approximation on them and this
is kind of what you get
when you kind of optimize your um
coloring profiles so that the
expectation is maximized
and you condition on the number of alpha
management sets that are available this
is kind of the variation you get out of
that
okay thanks
more questions
because again and uh we convene we
convene at
uh 11 30 pacific time which is in 35.